foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and today it's going to be a special one
today
um there's we have one guest we're not
going to do q a we are just going to
talk it's a craft episode of black man
beyond where uh where my guest and I Ed
Brubaker who I'm sure you all know and
if you don't know go do your research
um
but
um comic book writer TV writer animation
writer graphic novelist
um I'm pretty sure there's some other
forms of of words smithery he's done
that we'll discover uh over the course
of the next hour or so
um and I can't wait to do it because
every time I talk to Ed we we end up
just talking about writing and craft and
the business and all that stuff for like
an hour before we get get on to talk
about whatever we're going to talk about
but he's got a new graphic novel to push
we got a big conversation to have before
we do that we've got to read a quick ad
um thanks to our uh uh our sponsor for
tonight's episode of black man beyond is
baluchu the knights are getting along
with kids but the breeze isn't the only
thing that's getting stiff
listen blue shoe is honestly giving us
the best ad copy in the game
um they know who they are they know
their audience they're not [ __ ]
around so yes that's right this episode
this episode is sponsored by bleach you
guys we all know that confidence can
take you far in life that's especially
during the bedroom especially when it's
time to step up to the plate and that's
where Bluetooth comes in bleaching is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but in chewable tablets and a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night you can plan ahead
or be ready for whatever an opportunity
arises process is simple sign up at
bleacher.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers but once you
approved you receive your prescription
within days best part all online no
visiting the doctor's office no organ
conversations no waiting in line of the
pharmacy and if you're a patriot uh
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and shipped directly to
your door in a discrete
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
chew it and do it at better sex with
Bluetooth and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try to bleach you free
when you use a promo code Fatman at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code Fatman receive your first
month for free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and as always we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
and sing We Did it you guys we didn't
have all without Kevin and you know how
long that ad took
45 seconds
who's who's better than us who's better
than you and me I don't know um but I
know who's better than me in writing and
that person is my guest today
Ed Brubaker
that was a the greatest intro of all
time I as a child I dreamed that one day
I would be interviewed right after uh ad
for erectile dysfunction
we're making dreams come true today and
we're making dreams I was like this is
actually the perfect thing for my CD
crime comics
um
I'm good how are you doing you know it's
a it's a it's a beautiful day in Zamunda
it is somehow 94 degrees in Los Angeles
uh in the the bottom half of October
um but you know I'm I'm getting to make
stuff up for money yeah exactly that is
that is it exactly how I wanna before I
forget I want to show the new Reckless
book to the viewers out there this just
came out last week or this week I can't
remember this week or last week whatever
week it is this video last week well you
were you're like purely in the graphic
novel business these days right like
that's that's how you make comics that's
that's sort of how yeah we transitioned
uh uh sort of by accident out of uh
monthly Comics to just doing graphic
novels uh during the early days of the
pandemic we we had a graphic novel like
a shorter like 72-page book that we had
put together
uh and it went to the printer the day
that the entire industry shut down and
so it was just sitting there for months
and I just thought well what are we
gonna do and I you know out of a panic
I'm like I'll just start writing a
graphic novel series and so you know we
did five of these Reckless books in uh
it's a couple months under two years
we've put out five like 150 page uh Pulp
Fiction graphic novels about this you
know
sort of you know private eye sort of
criminal
who does the right thing through the
course of 80s La
um and they've just been a blast but
yeah it became
you know once I figured if the market
for Comics somehow didn't come back we'd
you know try to sell it to a book
publisher or something and then when the
market did come back the graphic novels
were just taking off like hotcakes for
us in the comic stores and
um just kind of instinctively we were
like okay let's just keep doing this now
because you know I think both of us Sean
and I really enjoyed not having to stop
at the end of you know every 24 to 32
pages and doing other cover and you know
only having to think of like a couple
covers a year is a lot easier for both
of us and uh and you know I think just
the momentum of writing a longer book is
just you know this far into our career
we're so used to we've been working
together for 20 years now a little over
20 years right so I think you know every
time we try to do something a little bit
different
um but but yeah doing you know just
going to graphic novels I feel like it's
freed up some other part of my brain
that you know I've spent my whole life
reading and drawing and writing comics
and it's like I get to sort of
experiment around with the form a little
bit more than I was able to even just a
couple years ago by you know just
publishing it in a different format it's
kind of crazy how how simple something
like that is
um you've been you have to have been
making Comics at this point for what 30
years or so 35 years I started
publishing Comics I was I when I grew up
I only started writing because I wanted
to have stories to draw and because I
wanted to be a penciler when I was a
little kid I wanted to pencil Spider-Man
or Captain America or Iron Fist
eventually I came around to deciding I
wanted to pencil the X-Men because
that's what all that's what all the kids
liked
um I never really understood it's too
many people I was like why would I want
to draw this comic it seems like it
would be so hard
um but I started writing stories for
myself to draw basically and then
at some point in my 20s I realized I was
much more of a writer than an artist and
I just started focusing on that I think
a lot of artists friends of mine kept
asking me to write stories for them and
I managed to you know do a few of those
and I would get the art back and it was
so much better than anything I could
draw that it sort of subsumed that kind
of satisfaction but yeah the first comic
I ever put out was like the late 80s
actually like 89 or something and wow I
was like part of the whole like
independent alternative Comics movement
in the early 90s in like San Francisco
and Seattle
so it's very uh long road of comics
are you still a guy who outlines like
what's your what's your process when it
comes to writing account
I I do outline I I notebook
it's like somewhere between notebooking
and asking myself questions and actually
writing an outline like here's the
outline that I'm working on right now
which
you can see some of I hopefully that
didn't spoil anything for a freeze frame
um but it's like sometimes I'll be like
or maybe we do this or maybe we do that
and so I do stuff like that a lot where
I I like I I definitely
I'm somewhere in between
giving myself a net and leaving myself
enough room to improvise while I'm
actually writing to which you know from
like TV writing there's none of that
like if you be writing you have a scene
by scene beat by beat outline written
out so like that's part of the fun of
doing the comics is every now and then I
get to the end of a scene and I look at
my notes and I'm like I want to do
something else here next instead you
know and and I have the freedom to just
do that yeah because you know like I
don't I I always have to know where I'm
headed and what the end is but I don't
always have to know every single
decision on the way ahead of time right
yeah I mean I just it's it always
strikes me in talking to sort of
veterans at it yeah there's the thing
you do when you're young and you're
starting out where it's like right
here's my line here's my every page I'm
writing down that's happening on each
page just so I know and I can count and
whatever but then after a while so much
of that stuff becomes somewhat back
brainy and yeah secondary like you just
you start to know the rhythms of it and
understand it it's like all right well
this will take about this much room and
this will feel about right and and yeah
giving yourself the freedom to just like
I'm going to jump off this cliff and I
know I can land particular jump yeah I I
definitely during the that's been one of
the interesting things about switching
to graphic novels was like
I do feel like the second half of each
book so far for the last couple years is
like a slow panic attack that I messed
something up or forgot something or I
didn't leave myself enough room to
finish the story or you know and I I
always feel like they've ended up
working out but by the time I finish any
of them I'm like I don't know hopefully
this works and then other people read it
and tell me it's good and I'm like okay
good I trust them
um but I definitely you know I that was
part of what was exciting to me was like
trying to do something different and
because like what you said it's like I
know I'm when I'm sitting on to write a
story I generally know if I know what
the story is about or or if there's like
a twist ending or something that I'm
trying to really land I know
instinctively I've written enough things
especially if I'm working with like Sean
Phillips who I've worked with for so
long you know or but even like
screenwriting it's like I know I I know
enough about how to like make it make a
moment land I'm not I don't write with
that same kind of fear or that like
drive to prove myself in the same way
that I might have when I was in my 20s
or early 30s or something now I feel
like like I write yeah to and it's like
as long as I'm keeping myself interested
I am assuming you know I know enough
about how to do this that I'm probably
not screwing up and if I do hopefully
I'll be able to figure to notice it
before it prints and I can fix it you
know I spend the month before a book
goes to print just going over it with a
fine tooth comb to just shake take
anything out that bumps me or improve
the flow of dialogue in a scene or just
weird little things like that but um but
yeah I definitely feel like the the
um
this part of my life as a writer like
being you know like having been doing it
for 20 something years now I I
definitely have the kind of confidence
that when I start writing a book I'm not
worried that I'm gonna get 30 pages in
and be like I don't know where this is
going I I'm not going to write this and
start something else yeah
like I I I had started to get you know I
I started to feel the way because
remember hearing Harrison Ford describe
his performance it's like listen I'm not
an artist
I'm a crisp it's like I'm not like I'm
not gonna like I don't do what De Niro
does I don't know what Brando did I
don't do what these great actors have
done but I can build your performance
that will hold that will serve the
function that it needs to serve in this
particular movie
um I think you saw himself shortly sure
yeah yeah but that feeling of like every
time I sit down to a TV script even a
comic script it's like all right what's
the I can build you a chair yeah I know
how a chair works like I can build you a
thing that'll hold your ass and it'll
keep you afloat and like it's not gonna
be a restoration and Sierra's not gonna
be a mid-century modern show it's not
going to be a a Louis XIV chair but it's
good chair like it'll do that thing but
then we can sort of like get to to
filigree's and buffing and and
cushioning all that [ __ ] but like it's
going to do the job it was designed to
do yeah exactly it's not gonna be it's
not gonna be a footstool by accident
yeah I didn't maybe make a slide like no
yeah
it turns into a slide when you sit on it
so you know that's that's always my life
you know I'm confident the fact that I
can build you a chair now let's see how
nicer chair I can get for you you know
over the course of three or four drafts
of whatever particular show or or even
comic that it is
I feel like that's the biggest you know
the the hardest thing for me going from
Comics into like screenwriting like film
or TV and the thing that I you know
always subscribe
like whatever moments of like human
truth you're putting into these things
for for my Comics I'm always trying to
write
generally like something that I feel
like needs to come out of me almost like
therapy or something like I don't do
therapy so I write a bunch of stories
instead that are mining like all these
dark [ __ ] up things in my head and
nice things too
but they're they're easier to mine
um but uh but it's like I I feel like if
I you know if I don't write regularly I
start to lose my mind a little bit but I
noticed with like TV and screenwriting
there's a it's like how do you find
those moments when you're doing
something like like when I was a writer
on Westworld like there was nothing
about season one of Westworld as much as
there are things that everybody in that
writing room like put up on the board
and that ended up in the show like
that was a big learning experience for
me because I realized when you're not
the person who's in charge of the show
or at least the co-person who's in
charge of the show everybody else that's
there in that writing room is just there
to help them write their show like you
can talk about it any number of
different ways but as a writer what
you're really there for is for your
writing skills and hopefully your
whatever people skills you have and your
ability to sort of try to you know try
to write like them or try to help them
do the thing that they need to do and
you know with like that show like Lisa
and Jonah had like a five season outline
already like I'm watching the newest
season and I'm like oh that stuff we
talked about in week one
this is insane they actually stuck to it
but um but it was a big shift from doing
comics where even writing Captain
America or Batman or something like that
you pretty much get to write your story
for those characters for those Comics
because you're on these tight deadlines
it's a little bit sir like I wrote
Captain America for eight years you know
pretty much it was to the point where if
other people wanted to use him they had
to run it by me and my editor especially
with like the Winter Soldier and Bucky
like everybody had to run everything by
me and I would you know request dialogue
changes and stuff if I thought something
was too you know out of character
um
but film and TV it's like there's so
many different voices involved and it's
like how do you find a way to bring your
voice into these moments It's like
because you always want to be
yeah I mean I'll I'll pick the greatest
screen one of the greatest screenwriters
in the world you always want to be
Charlie Kaufman you know when you're
turning the script in you want your you
want your episode to be the one where
everybody's like holy [ __ ] we got this
guy
what's he doing on this show
but arguably like whatever episode of of
Westworld Charlie Kaufman wrote would
probably not have been filmable
yeah yeah either for budgetary reasons
or just depression
because you're right the job is you're
helping somebody else execute their
vision a lot of people don't realize
that too and I you talk to a lot of
younger writers coming in and I remember
the first
one definitely the first month on the
job there were there were several times
I got pulled aside during the first
month on Westworld at least two or three
times where I got pulled aside
to sort of
I was so excited to have the job and I
had been writing professionally for like
20 years by the time I got the job so I
was like what about this what about this
what I was like the the like guy
everybody else in the writing room was
like who the [ __ ] is this guy
um but I remember getting cold aside to
be like hey hey hey you not everybody
you know has written as much as you like
like remember to always leave room for
everyone else to pitch their ideas and
don't you know don't get overwhelmed in
those moments and I was like oh that was
a good learning You Know lesson to be to
be pulled aside and told I was
embarrassed of course but I was also
like that's that's good and I always
kept it in mind after that
um and I remember like Lisa on one of
our first weeks that we wrapped we were
all out for like drinks at this time
remember like afterwards and she's uh
the biggest thing to know like when
you're when you're on someone else's
show is to remember give as much of
yourself as you can to those to the job
and get as much experience as you can
from it but understand this isn't going
to be your place to sing your song
exactly you're you're you know you're
one of the Supremes you're not Diana
Ross it was like an interesting like way
to think about it because she was like
because otherwise you'll just get
crushed by The Experience it'll be a
huge disappointment for you you won't
get what you need to learn out of it and
you'll be bitter about that you didn't
get to do more you know as opposed to
hey you got to work on this amazing
thing and I see that a lot with like
younger writers who think you know oh I
don't feel like I was listened to by
like a showrunner or something and it's
like well I I mean talk to everybody
else in the room I'm sure they all feel
that way a lot of the time you know like
that's it's a tough job where and a
showrunner is often thinking about 40
different things at the same time they
may be thinking about an actor or a
budget cut that they don't tell you
about and they're looking at the board
and listening to a million things and
replaying like some phone message in
their head about like why the actor
decided not to show up that morning and
now they're trying to so it's like it's
a really tough job like and watching it
you know and then having done it with
refin like on our show and now this
Batman show like helping Bruce run that
like you know you just see the amount of
balls that are constantly in the air and
getting thrown at the showrunner to to
deal with I you know I couldn't possibly
do what Bruce Tim is doing on the show
that you and I worked on yeah I mean
it's it's I don't remember who I was
talking to it's another it was a it was
a guy who had been a shoulder for a very
long time and we were at a party and I
was like you know the thing they don't
tell us when we're starting out because
as you're a young writer who wants to
get into TV the dream is always I want
to run my own show yeah like that that
feels like the trajectory that everybody
is like no that's that's us that's the
Golden City that's that's the Finish
Line yeah I don't tell you was at the
best job in TV it's like supervising
producer it's like two runs away from
the top where it's you're still getting
a lot of money but nobody's calling you
at 3am from the set saying that oh my
God that person you know just got
covered who had to shut down for two
weeks yeah nobody's calling you because
they need the fourth draft of this this
thing that's going to happen that
they're in the loop yeah you're in the
loop but you get an email the next
morning yeah you still just get to go
home yeah and that's your job you don't
have to give notes on the director's cut
if you don't want to yeah I'm sure you
guys will handle it I bet you it's great
like you're not it's not 3 A.M when
you're on sin Prague it's really and I
think too if you're gonna be an
executive producer or a showrunner like
and this is all hopefully advice for you
know people I I try to tell a lot of
people trying to come out of comics into
TV and film writing like just be honest
with them about what it's like because
it's a completely different writing
experience yeah you know it's more like
being you know like an intern at a at a
hospital or something sometimes like
work-wise like sometimes your job is
just to come to work and sit around and
wait for the showrunners to need you you
know that day because they've got a
million things going on but they want to
make sure you're there for the two hours
they're gonna have to get in the writing
room
yeah and like most of being a TV writer
is not actually writing yeah most of
being a TV writer is sitting in a
conference room having a conversation
for anywhere between three and eight
hours a day yeah sometimes longer
sometimes 10 to 12 depending on the show
it can get like video game crunch time
yeah for sure and the
um
the the thing too is like it's never
done like you can write your script and
then it's like the show Runners doing
rewrites are asking you to do rewrites
you're you're shooting and something's
not working so you have to do rewrites
in the trailer on set and get that
approved by everybody and then get that
it's like the the that side of it like I
don't think anybody should ever want to
be like unless they've just got it wired
like a John Wells or somebody who just
can do it like as if it's not even
happening or something like where
they've just done it for so long it's
not a big deal like the amount of labor
involved people don't think about and
it's like don't do it unless it's the
show you are the most passionate about
and you were like I need to Midwife this
thing into existence because you know
like a lot of people don't know that you
know a showrunner or a head writer like
there's you know they may not have their
name on every script as a writer but
they've definitely written something on
every script and every episode of a show
you know because that's part of the job
is like they're the they're not calling
up the the writer at three in the
morning to make a change that needs to
get shot at six usually they're making
that change at their hotel room next to
the set you know so and they're like
okay and they're thinking of the whole
season where there's the writers
thinking of their episode you know it's
a it's just a really demanding job
having seen it up close I was just like
I mean I'm glad I was older when I
started Staffing on TV shows because I
don't know how anyone would find their
voice in that system to some degree too
like what is your voice like who knew
Noah Holly would you know go from go
from writing on Bones to you know
writing Fargo and figure out a way to
you know become I think the you know one
of the best TV writers working and
someone that definitely has like a point
of view on everything he writes yeah for
sure for sure and it's you know that
that is the challenge of you know and
you mentioned before how do you bring
how do you find
um enjoyment and validation and a sense
of accomplishment writing somebody
else's show like how can you how can you
find your way to be that okay standing
behind you yeah this night it's like you
see that little thing there that little
thing there was mine yeah exactly I did
that bit that little run that was that
was my thing yeah like it's like oh that
was my idea
but yes it was honey you find the way
and it's it's different on every show
and some shows it's just not possible
you know a lot of shows are like written
uh and people don't know this but this
is another thing that a lot of writers
rooms will do especially on network
shows that are in constant crunch
basically is the the
um Frankenstein drafts where they you
know have the outline and they break the
outline into you know C six five or six
people you know are given scenes and
write the scenes and then it's put
together and then the writer of record
will do a rewrite on that or a Polish
yeah the show run roll to do a Polish
and that'll be the script and a lot of
those people aren't credited because
it's just you know that's how it that's
how it's done and it's like so I mean
there's probably a ton of great scripts
that have been written that way I mean
the guys on Breaking Bad and Better Call
Saul they said their outlines were so
detailed they felt like anyone who was
in the room helping them break the
script you know could have written any
of those episodes like you know and they
would they would be different based on
what the things that people were saying
saying but generally they'd be pretty
similar right it's just the story we
were telling yeah some I mean some shows
are more like that than others and you
know it's it's interesting though uh as
a writer you really do have to
coming from Comics into TV the
compartmentalizing side of having been a
comic book freelancer too and having
worked for Marvel in DC really helps a
lot because you're able to look at the
all the different episodes at the same
time and plop you know map that stuff
out more if you've written eight years
of like a superhero comic with
continuity it's like you that part of
your brain is very helpful in a TV
writer's room you know just the
technical parts of it if you're really
into the technical craft side of writing
like that part of my brain is always so
fired up like working in a few TV
writer's room because it's like oh I can
help here like I can you know that's
something I can really you know take
part of and be passionate of I remember
early on when I was sort of trying to
find my way in that room and in that on
that show my friend kathleenfelter who
is like one of the best writers I know
and has been around TV for 20 30 years
like she was a writer else and a bunch
of network shows and stuff and I think
she was on Hannibal she's been on a
bunch of like Brian Fuller related
things
um but she just told me like try to find
one part of the show that you can sort
of take more ownership of like a
character that you really feel
passionate about and like you know
follow their trajectory and make sure
when when their Arc is being discussed
that you're you know getting input in
that it'll give you something to you
know to make sure that you feel like you
know I'm contributing here just mentally
because it can be a really I mean you
watch I mean writers generally
temperamentally are very well suited to
sitting at home alone
so putting 10 of them in eight or ten of
them in a room together there's a lot of
meltdowns that happen through the course
of the Season depending on how long it
goes too and people don't think about
that like the anxiety of having to go to
like a work job
when you're used to working I mean now
the pain endemic has made it you know I
think I think a lot of shows will
probably only do virtual writer's room
for the foreseeable future still yeah I
mean I think it depends a lot on on the
taste of the showrunner yeah you know
and and some of the the older ones that
I end up talking to and by older I mean
people who've done it for a while
they're like maybe I can't wait to get
back in a room yeah you know and I do
and I do feel that I do feel the there
is something about being able to read a
person's body language yeah to to to be
able to just see all of those Unwritten
things because so often being on a zoom
is waiting to talk and like when do I
get to say my I just oh I used to call
it pitch chicken of like two people just
trying to do it at once and then
somebody's got a blink
whereas like if you're in the room like
you can kind of feel when the time is
right yeah
yeah
finds those Finds Its Own momentum kind
of or it's Rhythm and yeah and also
there's an element of group therapy to
it which I find really amazing there's
always the you know what happens in The
Writer's room stays in the writer's room
kind of thing so people are
other writers that you become friends
with like we all end up revealing like
things about ourselves and our past and
stuff and we freely allow these things
to be mined for TV shows that we don't
own at all you know but then it's like
oh but that moment happened and it
resonates with other people in the room
and we end up putting it in you know the
show and it's like I think yeah that's a
really cool thing and it happens a lot
less on Zoom people are more guarded too
because they're being reported they're
they're more guarded and they haven't
like I remember the the card room you
know it it it was the room that bridged
the pandemic for me I started that show
in like February yeah and then March hit
so like I got to meet in the room
physically with people oh wow and then
it was oh [ __ ] we got to shut it down we
gotta like everybody all right go home
we'll figure this out and so I didn't
really know anybody yeah in the we're
gonna sit down and have a lunch together
we're gonna walk to and from our cars
together we're gonna have all of those
times where we're not actually writing a
show to kind of it's you know the first
week of camp like we never got to have
that and so every time we got on the zoo
the zoo always felt like work we're here
to do the thing let's talk about the
story
um and then we're signing off and I'll
see you later and yeah nobody wants to
stay on the zoom an extra hour and just
[ __ ] yeah there's no bullshitting
there was like the five minutes one
brings Donuts every Friday that's not a
thing that happens yeah there was no
like we all need to walk off this giant
fried food lunch that we had let's let's
go around the block and we'll yeah I
loved that the walking around we would
do that during our yeah we'd eat lunch
and then we'd go for these hour-long
walks and come back and go into the
editing Bay and watch you know dailies
or cut types of stuff like there's all
the the camaraderie of of it that you
know as a comic book you know nerd who
worked at home my whole life like those
parts of it I was like oh this is
totally different and fun oh art
Department people I can go in and get
and talk to those people and see what
the show's gonna look like and you know
like there was parts of it I I don't
think you know I learned it was it was
hard on the reference show because I was
for for about half of it I was the only
writer and then we brought on my friend
Ally to to you know help you know do
rewrites and stuff
um but those were weird work days
because we were working at you know I
would sometimes meet him there at seven
in the morning and we would work for
three hours before you went and shot all
day or something right I would or I
would meet him at 10 o'clock at night
after he'd been shooting all day working
until two in the morning and you know so
I wasn't I would not be around the
office a lot after that because I would
be like I have to go home right like I I
gave Darius Bunji my office pretty
quickly when I realized like
I'm gonna be in the conference room in
meetings or at home doing rewrites like
clearly like I'm not I don't I do not
need an office it is a luxury Darius
needs an office
um but yeah it's it's uh it's just a
weird job where you know you end up
using your technical skills a lot more
in a in a way than I think people
realize
that they're going to in a way everybody
assumes when they're gonna do a TV show
or a movie like because you know you
know in the old days when you wanted to
work in TV you had to write an episode
of a different show like you wrote an ER
or a Gunsmoke yeah you'd expect
something to show that you could mimic
the voice of another show that was
currently on the end yeah and then you
could get high because it's like oh this
guy knows how to do that and but for the
entire time I've been working in TV you
write spec Pilots so you're showing that
you can come up with your own thing and
then getting hired because they're like
oh this is interesting this guy's got an
interesting writing style come right
like come write our show and we will and
you won't be able to do any of that
he'll be there but your technical skills
are good and you have a good imagination
and so it's it's a really fascinating
job I I think you know
it's one of those things you really have
to love you really I mean you have to be
a writer you know instinctively to want
to put up with how hard it is to make a
living as a writer anyway yeah I think
about all the people who write novels
who work regular day jobs outside of a
creative field at all and their life is
waking up three hours early so they can
work on their novel every morning or
staying up late so they can work on
their novel every night and these people
are still publishing books and you know
and our creative forces that are writing
their stories and you know it's just an
incredibly hard field to be lucky enough
to make a living in you know and so you
kind of have to remind yourself of that
all the time and then also like if you
want to work in TV it's like I've
decided that I wanted to work in TV
while watching an episode of like
Breaking Bad or The Sopranos or
something I just finally was like you
know what I should just try and work
into be they're doing so much stuff that
I love that's like the kind of stuff
that I wish I could write more of and
comics and you know and I just thought
this is you know this is a serious
medium now like I love TV as a kid I
would have happily like taken a job
writing episodes of The Twilight Zone
you know which had ended years before I
was born but still like you know or I
would have written for Dobby Gillis
or Gilligan's Island
but but like really thinking about it as
like a creative Endeavor like I didn't
you know I didn't ever imagine that you
could have the kind of uh freedom I just
assumed it was just like a glamorous job
in TV or film I assumed you know because
because I watched movies and TV shows so
I assume that the lives of the people
who work in these things are like that
and in reality they're all just people
working jobs they're just the same as
you know every now and then a movie star
stops in but they don't want to be
treated like one so right so we all just
have a sound like everybody else yeah
yeah oh no I'm just gonna sit you know I
was having lunch with Toby Jones one day
on a Marvel thing and I just thought
this guy just seems like a guy who likes
a lot of the same boobies as me
you know so I was like I know he's one
of the best actors working right now and
he's there to just do voice over as
Arnhem Zola
and and here I am having this lovely
lunch with him but it's really it's like
a factory town and like the jobs are
jobs like eventually
that becomes ingrained into you that
it's like this is work and it's a job
and we're making TV shows
I heard Vince Gilligan in an interview
say it's just as hard to make a Bad
episode of a show as it is to make a
good one and you don't know when you're
making it which one it's going to turn
out to be yeah that was like a
revelation to me to hear that because I
just thought here's a guy who I think
just about everything he's written is
genius you know even his crazy episodes
of The X-Files which were always the
weirdest ones
um so like and here's him someone who's
been in the industry for that long and
it's like yeah everybody you know
everybody has those moments where
they're like well that didn't work out
yeah it was it was a huge lesson for me
as well because I I think I like you
started
I I was a Critic for a long time yeah
you know I was a video critic I was a
movie critic I I did a bunch of
criticism for Entertainment Weekly
specifically yeah and that could be
brutal on things because yeah you know
to a certain degree that's part of the
job but also it was easier oh yeah the
Venom flew slipped faster hating or
loving a thing is much easier than just
having to write about a thing you
understood and appreciated but yeah
too late it was much easier to you know
to interview to review a movie I really
despised in something like the Stallone
Judge Dread where I'm just like
I mean yeah it's a movie
yeah like b-minus is the hardest grade
to give because it's like you know it's
not like awful it's not good it's just
kind of
I remember that you were a known like
critic when you came into writing Comics
at wildstorm back in the day I remember
that was like a bone of contention and
among some people it's like well why is
this guy getting hired he's a Critic and
and everybody being like oh he's a good
writer though
that's part of my big pitch early on was
like listen guys I've been working for a
Weekly Magazine for nine years yeah I
haven't missed a deadline yeah this is a
periodical business and so like even if
it's not great because it won't be
because these are my first Comics
they'll be on time it's like yo you will
have your scripts but you also had chops
and you knew Comics like I didn't read
your first comics and think oh this
looks like a guy who's gonna be good
someday but seems very amateurish I just
thought oh this guy's good he knows how
to write Comics like I didn't there was
there were no obvious bumps yeah of like
first-timerness
kind of you to say because now that I
read those Comics back every now and
again I'm like
oh yeah no I can't even I can't look at
my stuff from when I first started out
I'm like why did I think I could put 85
words in a balloon what was wrong with
me just break it into three balloons in
one panel what is wrong with you
Brubaker you used to let her you know
better
what is a what's what's a day in what's
a day in the life they have Brubaker
what's what's your writing day feel like
well I'll tell you my ideal one which I
haven't been hitting a lot this year
just because this year's been a little
bit of a roller coaster ride on home
life stuff
um but ideally I get up early in the
morning whenever I wake up I don't set
an alarm I'll just wake up sometime
before the humanity has risen usually
while it's still dark I like to try to
get the last hour of Darkness into the
day before LA or wherever I'm at at the
time totally wakes up and I'll look at
whatever I've written sometimes I'll
check my email first if I'm smart I'll
wait to do some writing before I check
my email
um but uh I try to you know on the on
the days when I'm sticking to my plan I
get up and I open my file from the day
before and I look at whatever the last
you know four or five pages that I've
written of what everything I'm working
on and I try to do
you know before I really do anything but
drink a cup of coffee I try to you know
just keep working on whatever that was
if I'm if I'm in the middle of a scene
I'll try to finish that scene and
hopefully start the next one I usually
try to not end
um and a day of writing
uh without leaving something like partly
there for the next day like even if it's
just the opening line of narration or a
description or like okay and this is
what happens next a little jotted note
for myself so that when I sit down like
if I finish a scene and then I'm like
all right I'm wrapped for the day the
next morning sitting down to write will
take a lot longer than if I've got like
fragments of the narration for the next
page because then I can sit down and be
like oh okay I don't know start fixing
that and you know oftentimes I'll write
temp things and I'll do it in italics
I'll be like and then something like
this this and this and I look at that
and I realize like I wrote it so quickly
that it actually is kind of eloquent and
I'll just re-jigger it a little bit and
change some of it so that it's like an
eye instead of a he or something and
then he does this slowly look and then I
did this
um but that really helps me you know
keep the momentum of something going
um and I'll try to put in you know two
to four hours I'll you know I'll write a
little bit you know while I'm drinking
coffee and then I'll have breakfast and
then I'll try to put in you know two to
four hours in the morning and then in
the afternoon I'll try to you know catch
up on you know business emails and
whatever phone calls I might have to
answer and and then you know maybe get
you know on a day that's not too hot
like today was too hot but uh I'll go
out and ride my bike down to the LA
River and just kind of ride the L.A
River back and forth for an hour or two
and think about you know whatever needs
to happen next and the screenplay or the
comic script or whatever and you know
get a little bit of that out and sort of
try to save myself from having sat for
five or six hours straight to the
computer
which seems great when you're in your
30s but when you're in your 50s you're
like oh I'm killing myself great great
I'm turning I'm literally turning the
stone in front of this thing but
um that's my ideal working schedule
would be to do that five to seven days a
week get up spend two to three to four
hours just writing and then get away
from it and just do the thinking reading
research notebooking but you know two to
four hours of actual typing on pages is
I think about all my body and my brain
can really handle I remember Kurt
Vonnegut wrote from eight in the morning
until noon and he said in his experience
as a writer he'd learned that he
couldn't be he couldn't be required to
be intelligent for more than four hours
a day consistently and so he chose to
put those four hours into his writing
and like a lot of writers I've noticed
will say that like uh um you know look
uh John le carray uh you know said you
know give the first part of your day to
your writing so he would get up early
and have tea and just sit on his couch
with his notebooks for two or three
hours I know
um Walter Mosley gets up and I believe
still in whatever he slept in he
literally gets up and just sits sideways
in bed and has a desk next to his bed
and he hand writes in his notebooks that
way for two hours every morning and
that's how he writes a book or two every
year
uh he does that seven days a week he
said he did that the day of his father's
funeral
like a lot of when you get but I feel
like that's really that's the ideal like
I you know I have enough work that I
could literally be doing that and I've
just I've had some frustrations where
I'm you know not sticking to my schedule
so I'll have a couple days where I don't
get writing done and I'm on the phone
you know talking movie you know job
stuff with people or helping someone on
you know their outline or something like
that and so it's like some sometimes my
days are so divided up that I don't make
the time later in the day to just devote
two or three hours to sort of shut down
email and turn off the phone and all of
that and really just focus and I find
the later in the day it gets the harder
it is for me to not just be like ah I'll
just do it tomorrow so like if I don't
get anything done by noon you know
sometimes I'll be seven or eight at
night sitting at the computer just
trying to make sure I get at least a
page or two written that day
um because I always have you know the
the great thing I think for me is Sean
Phillips like I mean there's a lot of
Reason John Phillips is the great thing
for me but but the fact that he is so
prolific and he you know is is always
meeting pages and you know so he helps
me get out of my way on decisions a lot
like if I get too far ahead of him on
something I'll start agonizing over
every decision I'm about to make and
then when I see he's five pages behind
me and he's gonna need Pages soon
suddenly all the decisions become much
easier to make and I and usually I end
up realizing that the thing that I
thought of first that I wanted to do
that I started second guessing myself
about was actually the right thing or
the daring thing or like you know okay
well maybe I started second guessing
myself because I was worried about how
people would react to that and you know
I that's another thing I always you know
try to tell people as a writer too you
cannot think about the reader while
you're writing like and a lot of writers
do and they like they've no one's ever
like no writing Professor has ever told
them that like you're writing the story
sometimes I'm writing a story and
suddenly I'm like
I don't know where this is going exactly
like I know the end of the story but I
don't know the next 30 pages of this and
I'm like
[ __ ] what is it gonna be sometimes
stories go in a darker place than I
thought they were going to and you just
have to follow like the truth of these
characters and I think I see people
sometimes being worried they're like oh
but if I write something this dark
people will think that I'm that way and
it's like no like we all have all these
things inside of us we contain
multitudes everybody that you've met if
you're an intelligent creative person on
some level almost everybody you've met
you've at least briefly imagined an
inner life for that person and what
their you know like anybody who's made
an impression on you if you thought
about that you'd be like what is their
home life like what do they do what is
you know what is their you know they go
out they go out to bars a lot more than
I do like what's that like like we all
think about that and put ourselves in
the heads of all these different people
that's what's great about being a writer
is that you can look at so many
different sides of all of these
situations and all of these people and
try to put yourself in their head I mean
it's not always easy and you know a lot
of people do a really shitty job of
trying to write people whose experiences
are so completely different than theirs
you know but at the same time there are
a lot of people who are really good at
it who can write anybody you know or any
or any situation and make it believable
because they put in like whatever work
they needed to do to actually understand
what they were writing about yeah I mean
I I do I think and similar to you I do
deeply believe that you should be
allowed to write anything yeah there
shouldn't be walls between who you are
and what you write yeah but
you have to do the work yeah like that's
that is the actual Arbiter of it which
is are you going to do the work to
understand that person's life and why
that life is different from that other
person's life yeah and get under the
hood of it and see the truth of it and
then find ways to dramatize all that
like if you can do that then yeah right
right at all like be right exactly if
you're not going to be great then maybe
don't walk I'm alone you shouldn't be
walking on if you use something like the
wire as an example where it's like I
don't care who wrote The Wire because
it's a work of art like everybody
everybody who worked on that thing made
something that the people who lived that
world were like that's that's amazing
yeah that's who we are that's yes
that to me is like that's the high water
mark obviously no one's going to do that
every time but but that's the kind of
thing where it's like you know if that's
what you're really passionate to write
about it's like I didn't I was really
passionate to write about late 40s
Hollywood so I spent you know
I think a year and a half on Research
after you know 20 years of reading books
about old Hollywood just because I was
fascinated by it so just but getting
very specific research and all of that
stuff is so much you know to the point
where I was watching old movies but then
also trying to track down old interviews
with people on the radio to be like
because that's going to be more like
what people really talked like because
movies are scripts you know it's like so
trying to get like oh what things did
people say back then that they wouldn't
say now and and you know because for me
it's all about like trying to
trying to find some Moment of Truth and
you know when you're writing a period
piece obviously something about what
you're writing
is reflecting a truth that's inside of
you but you're using this past era to
talk about it in a different way so that
people it's much easier to talk about
something like racism if you're writing
about a story that takes place in 1948
you know in some ways or you know then
it then it might be to to write one
about what's going on in the country or
the world right now because people read
a story from 1958 and think about the
context and you know it's like it's it's
not so in your face and like choosing
you know like it's just I don't know I
find it very helpful to to be able to to
write about the way the world Feels
Right Now by writing about the way it
felt back then too in a strange way like
you know
well it's the it's also the same thing
it's it's genre
getting that genre allows you a certain
bit of distance from the subject you're
writing about even though you're 100
writing about it yeah and so like
science fiction as genre gets to do that
sort of historical fiction and genre
gets to do that yeah you know like the
Twilight Zone got to do that in almost
every episode so what is this one about
oh this is about yeah this one's about
it's amazing yeah for years I wanted to
do a biopic or a mini series about Rod
Serling I want to try to get Bill Hader
to play him because I think he'd be
perfect that would be amazing um but his
story is so fascinating because you know
he came home from the war from like
Korea or something like shell shocked
and you know I think a package fell on
the guy standing right next to him from
an airdrop so he was like killed by
friendly fire air drop and said the guy
and not like I think scarred him and you
know but he became one of the two
biggest writers in like original TV him
and Patty chaiyowsky were the the two
like Titans of that era and he quit to
start the Twilight Zone which everyone
made fun of him for like people thought
this was the biggest mistake he's got
the greatest career but one of the
reasons he quit was because when they
did a rebroadcast of
um Requiem for a heavyweight there's a
line where someone says you got a match
and the sponsor of the show was a
lighter company so they made them change
it to a lighter and then they use the
sponsor's lighter and that was just the
last straw was like I'm not I'm making
works of art I am not making things you
know I'm not making product placement
um he was so incensed about the sensors
and the and the studios basically just
changing things because sponsors and so
he decided he'd do this crazy you know
sci-fi Anthology thing and it ended up
being you know a huge pop culture
touchdown it changed the culture but he
also got to write about all the same
stuff that he wanted to but no one
[ __ ] with it yeah no genre is
brilliant for that I I remember when I
first started reading Mysteries like I'd
grown up watching mystery movies and
watching film Noir and you know uh my
dad was obsessed with uh taking us to
like the Hercule Pro movies when they
came out and stuff but I'd never really
been much of a mystery reader I read
Noir books like Jim Thompson and you
know the all the black lizard writers
but for some reason Mysteries I hadn't
really read and
um I was working at this bookstore on
Castro Street in the 90s
um it was this little used bookstore and
this author came in one day to drop off
like some of his books to see if we'd
sell them and it was this gay author who
was like a lawyer and he wrote murder
mysteries about this this lawyer in the
LA and San Francisco gay communities and
you know and and it was interesting
because in the book he was talking about
all these social issues that I was
seeing happen all around me in you know
the Castro including like things that
people couldn't really discuss in a way
because it was so controversial in that
like especially during that time period
the AIDS activist there was a split
amongst AIDS activists that no one
really talked about much at the time
where it was like there were AIDS
activists who were HIV positive and
there were AIDS activists who were not
and the one the HIV positive one
sometimes would get so extreme that they
thought if you if you didn't have if you
weren't HIV positive you weren't really
part of the fight because it wasn't
really affecting you in the same way and
it was like this weird little internal
Schism in it in a small you know
community
but it was the first time I'd ever seen
it come up in a work of fiction like
someone was talking about that and I
just thought well that's really
interesting and then I was talking to
another person who worked at the store
and they were like that's what I love
about like mystery novels and stuff they
always talk about stuff that's going on
in the culture
and they're able to address that stuff
by wrapping it around a murder mystery
and so these are the things that are
just part of the character's lives and
they're able to address it without it
feeling like didactic or you know like a
polemic it's like oh yeah like there was
one there was like a stand-in for a
Marion Barry type who was like uh a guy
who'd gotten convicted a politician for
the Latino community in the book but
who'd gotten convicted of a bunch of
drug crimes and gotten out and ran for
re-election and got elected and it was
about how you know these communities are
so desperate to have a voice that
they'll be totally forgiving of their
politicians if they're still going to
come back and be the voice for them it's
like hey we don't have a voice so we
don't give a [ __ ] if he's books crack
so it was like it was interesting to see
someone addressing that in crime fiction
when you know I read plenty of straight
literary fiction and you know I'm always
pointing out that some of the best
Straight litter very fiction books are
actually crime novels like the Greek
Gatsby is one of my favorite crime
novels
like literally it's about a bootlegger
and it's a murder story it's also like
one of the most tragic like
heartbreaking books that you'll ever
read too so it's like they're not
exclusive and I think you know
I mean that was that was part of my my
Discovery working on Castle Rock which
was like I read a lot of Stephen King as
a kid because we all did because he was
[ __ ] everywhere with Stephen King but
kind of getting under the hood of those
books and then realizing is like oh this
guy is actually one of the Great
Character writers in American letters
but we don't think of him as such
because it's Tommyknockers and it's Cujo
and it's Christine and it's like the
horror of it has kind of overwhelmed in
the public opinion the fact that he's
very very good and yeah looking
characters and then crashing the
supernatural into them yeah it's really
weird to I actually have gotten into him
later in life in a way like I read some
of his stuff when I was growing up
because everybody was and and I always
thought that different seasons book was
my favorite thing which was those four
short stories that had you know and
three of them are turned into movies of
course because everything is but um but
they all gonna turn into pretty good
movies too yeah but uh but like I've
noticed that about him I was reading The
Outsider I think was my first thing
where I read it and I couldn't put it
down and I just I loved almost all the
characters in it and the way the story
was being told and I I loved that it
felt like a murder mystery that you knew
early on like something is off here and
it's Stephen King so you're expecting
Supernatural but yeah the the way he
Blended the supernatural into the story
and also managed to in the book there's
a whole Luchador uh storyline which is
left out of the TV show which I I feel
was like that's like leaving the heart
out of it
movies was sounded amazing but but um
but yeah I I found that I was like I
love all of his character like even just
minor characters in his story is to end
up having so much real life and Trauma
and you know also man he doesn't at all
worry about like our viewers gonna think
this is too far like nothing he writes
does he ever think for a second oh I
hope people don't get sick when they're
reading this
you know and it's like that's what I
think about a lot when I'm you know when
I'm writing it's like okay well is this
too much or is this is this delving into
too much Darkness inside you know
humanity and which means that that piece
of darkness is somehow inside my mind
too and am I revealing it's like you
can't think any of that stuff because
you just have to be true to your story
you know even if you're gonna have your
character do something really awful it's
like well he's not me right oh I did
Dory it's not actually happening
yeah I don't I don't understand that
compulsion that I see sometimes from
fans uh you know when I used to be on
social media I never I I never got it
aimed at me but sometimes I'd look at
like TV shows I liked and you'd see
their fan base like yelling at them
about things that the characters did or
decisions characters made and I was just
thinking like I don't know I mean people
do lots of weird stuff like not
everybody always has to be the most
virtuous person sometimes it's
interesting when a virtuous person does
something bad or you know or like you
know in Batman like like if there's a
portrayal of Lucius Fox where he's not
the most you know benevolent person who
ever lived of all time like what if he's
what if he's greedy you know like like a
normal human businessman might be
it's like it's weird I I think that you
know you have to think about that more
like what's interesting to the story
what's what's honest to these characters
necessarily for whatever story you're
telling too yeah I mean I think that
that you know in for for the largest
part of the audience they first came up
against that as far as I can kind of
recollect what's Game of Thrones was the
awful things are happening to people
that you love and the people that you
love are doing awful things yeah and and
the the lesson always became like listen
nobody there's no fan who would have
asked for the Red Wedding but the story
needed the Red Wedding to happen and
it's necessary for it to work like
that's where these characters were going
that's really interesting
because you say no I I agree with you no
one reading the book when they saw the
Red Wedding coming was happy everybody
but you couldn't put it down yeah the
people who wanted the Red Wedding to
happen in the TV show where all the
people who read the book so they can
watch their friends it's like oh they
were like oh no you got to come over for
this episode trust me this is the best
episode you're gonna be so happy
you know and it's like that's that's
what great story can do like it takes
you to places you didn't think it would
go and then a fan would never ask for it
it's never fan service yeah it's give me
what I need not what I want remember
when you were a little kid did you ever
when you were a kid in elementary school
did the teacher read books to you yeah
like we when I was in the third grade
remember they read us Where the Red Fern
Grows which is a classic book I'm gonna
spoil for because No One's Gonna read
this book that's watching this podcast
it's a book about a kid who gets two
hands who hunt raccoons it's like a 50s
or 40s period bees or something his dogs
both die keeping him alive while he's
freezing in the Wilderness at the end of
the book and it's like no one in our
class or anyone who ever read that book
wanted those dogs to die but it was a
heartbreaking touching story that
everyone has remembered for that heard
that book or read that book as a kid you
can never forget those dogs saving that
kid's life no it's like sometimes that's
what a story demands is something shitty
to happen to your favorite person in the
book yeah it's like it's half I'm drawn
you have comedy you have tragedy and so
like give me the tragedy like I I like
flowers for algernaut is one of my
favorite stories yeah and it's
heartbreaking in every way I think can
be heartbreaking but like oh you didn't
get to the end what happened
happily ever after man it was the
smartest guy in the world and I was like
oh I'll catch the end of this at some
point yeah
oh wow oh so he became smart right yeah
I get it never read for president and
everybody wins yeah
um and then he was like being there
right
but yeah that feeling of like yeah no
bad [ __ ] like into every life of a
rainless ball it's part of the reasons
why we ingest story it's part of the
reasons why yeah the human existence is
what it is and so to pretend that it's
not gonna happen to pretend that
everything should go the way you want it
to go as a as a customer as a reader
viewer and it's like just tell me your
story man like something I'm gonna like
something that I'm gonna hate but what's
this story according to you and there's
something too about like creating an
experience for somebody I mean sometimes
you do have to think in terms of the
larger pop culture around something
because it's like you don't want to kill
off a character if that's been the trend
that's happening everywhere then it's
more surprising not to and you don't
want to do the thing that just feels
like a Trope to you so sometimes even if
logically you're like yeah this person
should die now or get tortured to death
or something it's like yeah it's been
happening too much I'm gonna do
something else but right that's the
weird part about it is when you think
outside of that but it but I do agree
it's like the and Game of Thrones had it
so rough because they I think that show
started like right around the same time
Twitter
existed you know like it's like before
that you couldn't get into you couldn't
really give your opinions to the people
running your TV shows like I was
thinking about this recently as you know
I read some article that Kieran Gillen
uh sent around in his newsletter called
the internet is already dead or
something like that and it was I don't
totally understand everything the guy
was saying because I'm not his internet
Savvy as the guy who wrote it but he was
basically sort of saying it's already in
its death spiral and and we all sort of
secretly know it and want it to happen
and
um you know and it made me think about
like just think about how many social
media driven news Cycles you've watched
happen and how tired of them you are
like I never need to hear hear about
Florence Pew ever again or Olivia Wilde
like I don't care like what they're
doing like they just made a movie it
seems like
um but but how many news Cycles are
taken up like almost every time a TV
show comes out now like there's weeks of
news Cycles where the cast has to stand
up to online trolls about stuff and I'm
like you don't have to do any of that
you can just ignore those people
completely like standing up to them is
giving them what they want to large
degree I don't think
you know a few thousand people on
Twitter and Facebook really make any
difference to a show that's being
watched by 40 million people
and like in the old days there was like
a crank file like people had to send I'm
sure Betty Davis and Judy Garland and
every actor in the world got death
threats and hate mail every you know
like mailed to the studios and stuff but
people went through the mail and pulled
out the nice ones and threw the other
ones in the bonfire or sent them to the
FBI if it seems like a serious threat
like people didn't necessarily think it
was a great idea for actors or creative
people to personally interact with
trolls you know like but now it's just
like I hear of actors who it's in their
contract that they have to maintain a
social media presence 100 and it's like
I would never be like take a job where
they said oh and by the way you have to
spend x amount of time on social media
every week I mean there there are there
are choices in casting
somewhat based on how big of a social
media following do you have oh I've seen
that many times you know and so the the
the idea that that is where you sell a
show because commercials don't work you
know trailers don't work so that you
have to go where the people are and the
people are on Tick Tock and they're on
Instagram and they're on Twitter and
they're on Snapchat and they're on
whatever
or you could just make something like
the bear which I didn't see any
advertising for and everybody left this
one's a huge hit right or or but that is
also that's the weird inverse of yeah
12 000 people loved it
nobody else knows it exists hey come on
I live in Silverlake everyone loved it
I heard it playing for my neighbor's
windows
it's been a little bit over the hour
um but I just want to like to leave to
leave the people with a thing to leave
the people with something actionable
leave the people with something that
they can they can apply if they're an
aspiring writer if they're looking to
make a career ship they're looking for
whatever
if you have to give a person a piece of
advice instead of just bitching about
the industry for an hour which we could
have done for another five well I I will
say the thing that I always try to tell
to people I mean you know it you're a
writer you've been a writer your whole
life whether you wanted to be or not
like that's a thing about writing is
like you either you either you are a
writer or you aren't a writer at some
point it will become clear to you
because you will continue to have to
write no matter what else is going on in
your life so like if you want to write
TV there's lots of ways into that now
like when I started trying to get jobs
in TV having been a writer in comics
meant nothing at all like they that was
a literally like only people's
assistance new people from Comics now
all the studios are run by people who
grew up reading comics who are those
assistants but it's like it really is a
thing where you know you can't give up
on it but I feel like real writers
like and real writers but like people
who are really just like this is who
they are that's their that's their
identity like they couldn't give up if
they wanted to like no you know even
Salinger supposedly just continued
writing for 40 years without letting
anybody see it but you know it's like if
it's in you it's in you I used to think
it was just Comics like that Comics was
almost this cursed because you always
because it's such a beautiful art form
and it's a simple like one to three
people can you know make a thing with
almost with no budget basically and you
know it's an elegant art form words and
pictures it's just so simple and I
thought Comics was a thing that was like
if you fell in love with Comics young
enough you were just cursed to want to
do comics for the rest of your life but
I feel like it's it's like that with any
kind of creative Endeavor really is
because I've known now so many people in
film and TV that you know have suffered
through how hard it is to get a TV show
made that they love or a movie made that
they are really proud of and yet the
second they're done with it they can't
wait to get back to doing it again you
know and I'm just like it is such a hard
industry to make a living in or make
anything good you know it's a miracle
that any of them get made at all and any
of them coming out brilliant is just
like holy [ __ ] I guess someone stayed
out of someone's way or someone trusted
someone or just or just everything came
together perfectly and this one worked
and you know a lot of the best ones
didn't end up making any money so you
know so it's it's even more of a miracle
when like a Fight Club happens or
something because it's like that movie
lost money and we still talk about it 20
something year 23 years later
but yeah that's my my advice to people
is just kind of like there's so many
paths in now for everybody that you know
if you're passionate about that stuff
just keep at it and find your paths in
you know all the studios I think have
you know trained screenwriting TV
training programs now I know a couple
people who've gotten into full-time TV
careers over the last 10 years who went
through those programs you know which is
insane to think that that actually is
the thing they'll train you how to write
TV shows for them and then they will
hire you to work on them
funny but you know not everybody can get
in those but it's like there's all these
Pathways in and I feel like you know
they're making more TV and film now at
least TV they're making more TV than has
ever been made in the history of you
know the universe
unless there's a planet somewhere we
don't know about that has nine netflixes
but what would your what would your you
know positive writing thing that you
would say to people I mean I it's it's
similar to yours but probably less
optimistic than yours because because I
do think I do think that writers will
write and they yeah and it's a thing
that if it's if it's in you you're going
to do it and there's probably no way for
you to stop it but I would I would I
would advise a person who wants to be a
writer
to not be hung up with the medium you're
writing in
because like as much as we make more TV
now than we ever have it's still a job
where 4 000 people hold yeah you know
and it's still very very hard to find a
way to get over that Hill
um you know but if what you want to do
is tell mystery stories you can write
novels you can write Comics you can
write [ __ ] that you're put on the
internet you can write you know you can
do a sub stack email like all of it is
available to you in ways that have never
been before if you want to make a movie
or you want to make your own TV show you
have a movie studio in your apartment
you can write shoot edit post put the
music on and distribute without ever
putting your phone down like all of that
is not possible but to divorce success
from accomplishment yeah you can still
be fulfilled in making a thing that you
show to your friends and your family and
then you maybe put up on the Internet
maybe somebody sees it maybe they don't
but you made the thing I will say too
that
uh I I know some incredibly successful
people from comics and film
I don't think I know any single person
who ever completely feels like they've
really
gotten there all the way like even the
most successful people I know they're
still they still want one more thing
they're still one more further you know
and it's like I you have to look around
every now and then even like even me I'm
like like it took me up until a couple
years ago I just kept always hoping that
Sean and I would be able to continue
doing our books and then someone pointed
out that we've been doing them for 18
years but I keep waiting for one of them
to be a huge hit
it's like you know they're all kind of
hits
like you can you can you know work for a
long time without realizing that you've
you've achieved a modicum of success and
not appreciate it because writers do
have that especially in TV or Hollywood
it's like I can't imagine being someone
who writes like tent pool movies or
something like that and yet every time I
see Michael Green hired for a job I'm
like I could have written that
I would have written Blade Runner I
probably wouldn't Blade Runner
just out of just out of fear of Ridley
Scott how much I loved the first movie
um but that's that's it it's just you
know be be realistic but be ambitious
and if you can do anything else you
probably should oh my God yeah you can
if there's something else that you can
do and make a living at like my dad
worked you know military intelligence
and Contracting and stuff his whole life
he wanted to be a writer he still wrote
on the side like when he when he passed
away he'd written I think he'd done like
one novel that you know eventually I'll
try and get published and and he'd
written like the first draft of a sequel
to it that were like these Vietnam spy
stories that are Loosely based on his
real life actually so I was like wow he
never really stopped like he had years
where he wouldn't write but he always
still had that you know ambition to to
do that so yeah and even if it's not
your day job it can be your safety valve
oh yeah I mean I will say if you're a
person who works in comics and also in
TV or film that is is such a savior
because you don't get as mad about the
things that you would get creatively
frustrated to the point of just nervous
breakdowns when you can wake up every
morning and write a few pages of comics
that are going to be exactly what you
want them to be it's it's much less
frustrating knowing that I have
one creative outlet that really nobody
else besides me and Sean you know have
any input into it's what we it's exactly
what it needs to be you know every time
we do it and because working in film
it's like there's the director if you're
lucky it's just you and the director and
a producer you know then you get to the
point where there's the studio notes
before you start shooting and then
there's this video notes after you're
shooting and then there's a studio notes
during post you know so it's like by the
time the thing gets made it could be so
far from what you thought it was going
to be so you have to like also think
about those experiences like who are you
working with like I will say every time
I've ever taken a job that I thought was
going to be a great career move for the
money or something like that it's ended
up just being like I wish I hadn't taken
the job I always try to come up with
what would be the great the great uh
like uh jingle for the writer's Guild
and that's like that that Smith song I
was looking for a job and I found a job
and Heaven Knows I'm Miserable Now
that's perfect yeah but let's end there
and thank you for taking time out of
your day today
one more time one more time Reckless
book five follow me down five books in a
year and ten months
I know I am so tired right now our next
book our next book comes out next year
and it's a totally different thing
hopefully I'll come back here and talk
to you about that I wouldn't love it I
would love it all right man um be good
uh and that is black man Bianca this
week um I have been Mark Bernardin this
has been Ed Brubaker
um next Black time uh same black Time
same black Channel broadcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith
um thank you be good take care be kind
to each other please
yeah seriously
greetings everybody all right and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith